as we were breaking up for the Christmas
period I was sort of looking at the
accounts going this is actually really
really difficult and then we came back
and we were like we're really gonna have
to pull a rabbit out of a hat here I
mean talking about the rabbit out of the
Hat the Oxford speech was the ultimate
rabbit out there I mean well for a start
it made a [__] ton of money yeah that
was the biggest thing is like we could
actually afford to pay everyone a salary
because if you look at our interviews
she went off the [__] deal with
we want to hear people's views from
different sides of the political
spectrum and there's not many places
that you're gonna get that variety of
conversation if you
you with someone that you just
then you're a child the values will
always remain the same we are always
dedicated to having the conversations
with the most interesting people about
the topics that people are scared to
confront proud of everything that we've
achieved oh mate the next the rest of
this year is going to be absolutely
Dynamite uh we've got I mean the stuff
we've got coming up exciting as hell
foreign
episode of trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster I'm Constantine kitchen and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with Fascinating People
today we're celebrating the fact that
we've just hit 600 000 subscribers on
YouTube and of course it's been an
incredible first half of the Year
Francis hasn't it it has been an
incredible first half of the year it has
been I think what is euphemistically
called a journey it has been a journey
mate well I mean one of the things
people won't know from behind the scenes
but actually at the end of last year the
end of 2022 we were having kind of a
rough time of it oh yeah we're having a
really rough time with it I mean we were
rapidly running out of money we were
well what happened was we we had to
leave our previous Studio as as as is
our nature yeah and uh we decided to use
that as an opportunity to build a proper
Studio from the ground up which is where
we're sitting now uh and we ramped up
our studio cast about 400 yep and then
immediately got covered and couldn't
work for a month basically uh towards
the end of last year so as we were
breaking up for the Christmas period I
was sort of looking at the accounts
going this is actually really really
difficult and we we had to cut the two
of us salaries which are not huge anyway
uh Anton as well
um uh and then we came back and we were
like we're really gonna have to
have to pull pull a rabbit out of a hat
here
and when we sat down at the beginning of
the year Laura who's our chief operating
officer now it basically runs everything
we had a planning meeting we were like
well wouldn't it be amazing if we could
get to 500 000 subscribers this year
that was our stretch go that was our
stretch goal because we were like we're
probably not going to make it no but
that would be great because that would
represent nearly doubling the size of
the channel in a year which is a huge
achievement absolutely it is and that is
what we were talking about and that was
a big Pie in the Sky the stretch goal
and I think it's fair to say we've
exceeded the stretch call well we're on
600 000 now it's it's the towards the
end of August now uh and we've still got
some incredible stuff coming later this
year which we will tease a little bit we
can't we never like to say exactly
what's happening until because every
time we do it never happens if you're a
multitude of difference someone gets ill
something gets canceled that's right
exactly but I mean for talking about the
rubber out of the Hut the Oxford speech
was the ultimate rabbit out there I mean
well for a start it made a [__] ton of
money yeah that was the biggest thing is
like we could actually afford to pay
everyone a salary yeah which was a
relief yeah it was it was because it
gets a bit awkward and you're going to
people and you're going you know that
work you've done which is has been
outstanding yeah well not in every case
not in every case but in the majority of
cases um
yeah how about
exposure would you like to get paid for
the exposure that old class we're not
we're not in the comedy industry yeah
exactly but um but yeah so the I mean so
what was it like for you to see that
speech well first of all like I say it
was a big relief because I think we when
we put that clip out of on our Channel
it generated about sixteen thousand
pounds yeah which meant that actually as
I say we first of all we could we our
financial problems were sort of taken
care of and then you just saw this video
get 5.5 million views on the channel uh
bringing a huge number of subscribers so
for me first of all it's just uh one of
the two people leading this it was just
a big way off our shoulders yeah than
anything
um and really
Beyond you know I I was I went on Tucker
again I did question time again I had
some in the immediate aftermaths and
opportunities that I'd had before but
again big ones
um you went on jbp's pod I did yeah yeah
would you would I think we've been
planning to to do it at some point
anyway but again that was that was
obviously great
but really not much had changed in my
day-to-day life because I don't live in
a big city uh most I'm very boring guy
most when I'm not in here working I'm at
home with my family going for walks in
the local park or whatever
um and so the only thing I I noticed is
I said to my wife like you know when I
used to go out in the local in the small
town that we live and maybe get
recognized once a week yeah now I I said
to her I'm sort of starting to get
recognized every day but you know it's
one person recognizes you when you go
for what it's not a big deal someone
says oh I love your show or whatever
and really it wasn't until we went back
to the US
that I started to gather the
significance of what had happened
because
we we were going to the us and this was
uh would it be our second proper trip
together filming and and doing stuff or
would it be the third one hang on a
second that's a really good question I
think it was a second trip the second
trip because the first trip we did we
did east coast and Austin and West Coast
that was one massive trip and then we
went back this time when we just did the
East Coast yeah didn't we we went to New
York Miami DC uh uh and uh you went to
Austin yeah and I went to LA to do Bill
Maher and a bunch of other stuff but
anyway when we set off I I drove into
Heathrow stayed in a hotel the night
before these changed yeah yeah I can
afford a hotel now uh and
um
between arriving at the hotel late at
night
and getting to
was a DC or New York airport wherever it
was I'd been recognized 10 times in the
space of about
what 24 hours yeah
and he was literally like I went down to
the pub in the hotel uh for a drink with
my son and a guy came over started he
had no idea he didn't know my name
didn't know anything about trigonometry
anything next day I take a cab to the
airport cab drivers like oh do I
recognize your voice and again you
didn't know about trigonometry this is
the thing like most people used to know
me just for trigonometry and now there
was a huge number of people who'd never
really known who I was who'd just seen
the speech uh the guy in the airport the
guy in security and the the it started
to get to the point where it's kind of
like almost a little bit worrying
because when we were in there was a long
queue when we arrived in the airport in
America yeah and me you Anton and Elliot
were standing around just talking about
yeah our business yeah and then you guys
went ahead to to for immigration and I
stayed back and the moment you guys left
the guy behind us stood there for an
hour listening to all our business talks
yeah when love your show by the way and
I was like why don't you [__] tell me
now hour ago so we didn't discuss
private information in front of you I
mean that's what he wanted that is what
he wanted yeah and so and then when we
got to America I suddenly realized that
like every all the people that we'd been
in touch with previously because they
were guests of the show or we would been
guests on their show whatever
they treated me very differently now and
it was It was kind of eye-opening really
so that trip to America really changed
everything for me because you know we
arrived then basically I was like all my
heroes are there saying you know welcome
brother yeah come and join us kind of
yeah it was it was almost an initiation
into a a world that I'd always aspired
to be part of and you know the thing
that really summed it up for me was uh
when I went on Bill Marsh show Eric
Weinstein he was a guy that you know
we'd been dreaming of having in the show
for ages so much respect for a
fascinating guy
um he asked to come and be my guest with
his wife and a friend of hers
in The Green Room whereas to me I I
would have been honored to like have a
coffee with Eric to that point we used
to speak every now and again on the fun
but it was just like
um amazing so it changed a lot I think
for the show because we pretty much I
don't know we would have got 550 200 000
subscribers from the the the speech
itself yeah and then the follow-up hits
that I did on various podcasts and TV
and stuff like that but also for me it
really changed how I think I see what
I'm doing and how other people see what
I'm doing uh my book I think doubled
sales in a week that's amazing I didn't
realize that yeah it did really well
particularly on the audiobook because
people wanted to hear literally hear
from the person that they'd heard so
yeah it was really it was it was
transformative and I feel
um it took a lot of pressure off me
actually really so it took some you know
the truth is that
I know that in the British context this
might sound arrogant but it is true ever
since I was a little kid I always felt
uh
I always had this weight on my shoulders
I felt that I was
supposed to do something special
and all my life I never
I I was always good at the things I did
when I ran my translation business I I
when I did comedy I was good at comedy
but I never felt that I'd really slot it
in you found your thing
I never felt that I found my thing
and with trigonometry I always did feel
like I'd found my thing but it was kind
of like having to prove it to the
outside world and I think what changed
for me with the Oxford speech it was
like
I've proved it now and and the way that
I feel now is like I have so much left
to do but I have nothing left to prove
that's an amazing place to be and it's
such a relief yeah you know it's a real
relief and it shows up in the way that I
am with other people in the way that I
am with my family and in what kind of
friend a husband or everything I am I'm
uh it's really allowed me to just take
that oh go go you know thing off me and
I'm free to be very driven and
passionate as I always have been but
without having this extraordinary
feeling of like I'm supposed to be
something and I'm not yeah yeah and I
think I think we've all noticed that and
it's
I think one of the things that no one
really talks about when you have success
is a relief element of it it's like when
we you know Nigel UNG the very famous
you know he's got that character online
which is absolutely massive I think he's
got over higher higher I think he's
probably got when we interviewed him he
had eight million subscribers he's
probably got something like 32 now yeah
exactly you're welcome exactly Nigel uh
but you know when I was talking to him
about the character I was oh were you
excited he was just like no I was just I
think he even said it in the interview I
was just like I'll thank the Lord yeah
you know it's that feeling of relief
that the work has been worth it yeah
because there's incredible people who
work all their lives and create stuff
and it's great but for whatever reason
it doesn't pop so that feeling of relief
I imagine is is just a sense of calm and
peace that it brings it is and also when
we went to the US there was we met all
these incredible people and the the
mindset over there that you you know we
talk about all the time it's got
downsides of course yeah of course it
does
but I really you know
I used to think the sky is the limit now
I just think there is no limit you know
I'm just like what what can we do uh how
can we be more of ourselves how can we
create amazing content how can we make a
positive impact on the world uh I'm not
embarrassed or shy anymore about having
Big Dreams and big aspirations for what
we're building here
um and I just feel like we we put
ourselves on the map yeah this year in a
way that I think in the past we just
felt like we were trying to yeah now I
just feel
um I feel like there's no limit and the
thing is it's not I know it's not a
delusional thing because I meet all
these people who are hugely successful
who I respect who we look up to who tell
us that they look at what we've built
here and they go there is no limit and
so to me this is all you know all
opportunity all upside all opportunity
from here on in doesn't mean we won't
have difficulties doesn't mean we won't
nearly run our money again but I just
feel like we've got a really amazing
team in place now who can allow us to
just be the on-camera personalities that
we are and create things and write
amazing comedy and books and you know we
should talk about all of that yeah we
should definitely talk about that
because that going forward
the the difficulty when you start ever
when you start something from nothing is
that you literally have to do everything
and the challenge with that is that the
things that you were doing
aren't really things that you know about
and aren't really your strength so
you're essentially doing things that
you're not good at but you are having to
model your way through well an
interesting example of this would be
when we went on Joe Rogan yeah uh and
then we went on Rogan he got a massive
uh blunt out which he smoked and then we
we got driven back to our Airbnb
completely off our faces having just
done Rogan and me you and me and you
were helping our team yeah set up fit
like actually putting the light stands
together while we're completely off on
that and doing all of that and then
interviewing one of our biggest ever
guests and interviewing to everyone who
roasted us for for an hour and a half
um and and that really you know that's
been the journey I mean it's interesting
we had a woman come into the studio
yesterday who was fitting some fire
extinguishers here and she was she
somehow had known our story and she was
like oh so you started in in the shed
didn't you and I was like no we didn't
it wasn't even our shed yeah you know
and that's that's been how we've done it
but you know something else I think
would be interesting to talk about is do
you know it's it's weird how
I feel like all the success that you and
I have had has always been because we
always had the mentality that the only
thing that could prevent us from being
successful is if you and I were to fall
out and not stick together and that's
not to say you and I have never had
arguments or fallings out or whatever
but one of the interesting things to me
was when my Oxford speech happened so
many people messaged me and they were
asking me if you were all right
and I just thought that is such an
interesting way of looking at it because
look I understand people sometimes are
resentful or whatever but I just feel
like everything we've built we've always
done it together so when I wrote my book
you look through and you help me punch
it up when you write your monologues I
look through it and help you adjust it
and whatever we've always done things
together yeah and so the success we've
had has been together but maybe I'm
wrong maybe you know what was it like
for you when that happened because a lot
of people were asking me about this so
for me when it happened there was a kind
of surreal element to it which was just
seeing the way that it went up and I
just had never seen that before
but
you know it was that time from for me
personally was a very worrying time in
terms of the finance I can't handle my
success in terms of the fight of
finances look I've been skinned I know
what it's like to be skinned and
whenever your skin
you carry that ramp with you a little
bit because you know what it's like to
you know have to Bunk a train because
you've literally got no money
you know what that's like so there was
that fear and then when it happened for
you I was so relieved and I was just so
oh he's like he's absolutely smashed it
he's pulled out of the boat and I was
delighted for you and I remember people
going to me and going oh are you jealous
and
no because this is what we built
together this is what this we're a team
I've always compared what we do to a
band yeah we're a band you know and so
the further you went and
you did this amazing thing it was
incredible for all of us it was
something I was genuinely proud of and
also as well it is completely what you
should be doing it's not what I should
be doing no no you know if I went on
there and I started banging on about
people about what you were talking about
people would be like
all right it's a bit because it's not
what I should be doing totally I think
I think jealousy like I understand the
emotion of jealousy of course I do and
the pangs that people feel and whatever
else but on a deeper level I genuinely
believe that
everybody's on their path
and what somebody is doing
it's not your path
so it's illogical you can take from it
is inspiration yeah which is and this is
why I think the fact what people
sometimes don't think about is it's like
that famous Yogi Bearer saying it took
me 10 years to be an overnight success
yeah
if if we don't have trigonometry yeah if
people don't already know who I am and I
don't already have a significant
following on social media I could still
do that speech if I'd been invited let's
say although I probably wouldn't have
been invited to speak at the Oxford
Union
and I do that speech
and it really wouldn't have the impact
either on us or the world that it did
because we'd put in the work to create
the foundation to launch something like
that you know
um
and that's it and that's it it's you
know the fact that it got us to this
point and look
when people talk about success and they
go oh you know it was because of this
reason or that reason the reality is
with what we've achieved
it's everything
it's everything and it's everyone and
certain people paid more of a part in
this factor and less people played more
of a part in that but it it's it's a
result of people working together the
danger comes with any type of creative
Endeavor like we have is when people try
to pick things apart and say it was me
who did this it was me who did this
because that encourages a the perception
of we're individuals doing this and once
you do that you're no longer a team and
once you're no longer a team then you're
not going to function I mean it's a
cliche but look at any type of sport if
you have a collection of individuals
doesn't matter how talented they are
they're never going to win the best
groups the best bands the best teams are
greater than the sum of their parts yeah
and you and I are incredibly different
yeah which is why I think it works yeah
it's it's a reason why it works because
if you look at our interviews the way we
attack our interviews are from two
completely different places yeah and as
a result of that you get a far more
well-rounded view of the individual in
front of us than you would do if it was
just me or you yeah and you know what
speaking of interviews I mean one of the
things that I have to say I'm incredibly
proud and excited of about is
some of the recent guests and the guests
that we've got up coming up you know we
have got everybody from Nigel farage
through to Mark Steele who's a lefty
Firebrand comedian to Aaron bastani the
founder of hyper Lefty uh media
organization Navara media and this is
what we set out to do when we started
yes we have our own point of view uh yes
we we're not pretending to not have them
but we want to speak to everybody we
want to hear people's views from
different sides of the political
spectrum and there's not many places
that you're gonna get that variety of
conversation including Navara media yeah
you're not going to get a at an
environment I mean they had my Goodwin
on but that was like a massive scary
thing for them and look good on them for
having them I'm just saying I think that
in terms of pioneering a new media
organization that is gonna have a range
of voices on it that you might agree
with or you might disagree with but
they've got to be heard and they've got
to be discussed and own an open and
honest way we're really really plotting
quite a unique course I feel and that's
something I think we should be very
proud of I absolutely we should and you
know and the this is the thing as well
there are interviews that we know are
going to get more views you just know
that you know that if you bring and I
love them to Pieces he's one of our
finest interviewees he's a brilliant
mind he's great fun Douglas Murray if we
bring Douglas Murray on we know it's
going to crush on every platform
it's going to be amazing
he's a star he's a star but
we also know that if you bring certain
other people on it's not gonna do as
well but it's important for the mix that
you get all these voices absolutely
because I and neither do you want to be
one of these Platformers where we just
talk to people that we agree with
because number one
and the most important thing about it is
just boring yeah if you cannot sit down
and have a conversation be friends have
a relationship with someone that you
disagree with then you're a child and it
really is that simple and I don't
understand why we don't talk about this
more yes well I think we've we found
ourselves in a very very locked in world
where
and look at it it's very gratifying
isn't it to just hear your opinion
regurgitated back to you and this Echo
chamber thing it exists for a reason
it's really you know what uh one of our
former guests actually Sean Walsh yeah
uh he probably won't even remember this
bit of material that he used to do he's
a comedian when I was starting our
comedy I saw him do a show and he at the
time this would have been 2014 believe
it or not and he was saying you know
what I don't know that we need other
people we just need a robot where you
just talk at it and then it says I agree
you are absolutely right and and so many
people just want that whereas look there
are things that I think you and I both
feel very strongly yeah that we've kind
of worked out for ourselves as a result
of the conversations that we've had on
the show and lots of things but there's
so many things that we do not know about
the world uh about all the different
things that we talk about on the show
uh that are worth discussing that are
worth debating that are worth chiseling
away at things and working out exactly
what it is that we think
um and we we live in a world that lacks
that and I think that's again another of
the reasons for for how far we've been
able to come and how far we're going to
go because we are going to retain that
attitude always We're not gonna get
locked into a particular world view and
aside
um which makes it difficult sometimes I
think I think we all know that if we if
we pick the team and started batting for
that team we'd probably be further along
in terms of numbers and revenues and
whatever but oh yeah it's just not you I
don't think you can be successful being
truly successful being something that
you're not no you can't you can't and
that's why your speech worked because
you were absolutely you
it was you distilled you weren't trying
to be something else you weren't saying
something that you didn't
wholeheartedly believe in and there's a
very famous playwright and I say it all
the time David Mamet words that come
from the heart go to the heart and
that's why that's speech connected and
that's why it was brilliant and that's
why it worked and I don't think people
actually
really understand that
because so many people are trying to be
something in order to achieve something
but you're never going to get there if
you were trying to be something because
immediately you're inauthentic and the
moment you're inauthentic it's when you
become people don't believe in you
because they know it's fake you know
what I think the truth is for us both
the the what we've been doing for the
last
five and a half years
is
chipping away at the Persona that we
thought we were supposed to have yeah
and actually get into the core of what
we are and who we are and what we
believe that's really been the journey
is like talking to people to try and
understand
what the truth is about certain issues
but also being free to speak our minds
because not that we we want to bang on
about it too much but when you are on
the comedy circuit and your livelihood
depends on people in the industry liking
you
uh in a very punitive industry where if
you have the wrong opinion people will
ban you from clubs or not book you or
whatever we had to really watch our
steps all the time and it creates this
kind of eggshell walking experience
that's just it's the worst thing it's
not the worst thing of course but it's
really really terrible it's a terrible
way to live your life and it's what it's
how most people live and it's why this
show is so successful it's because we
don't live like that and when we have
conversations which are open and honest
in which we say what we think and we
feel
that's for people that's revolutionary
because most people in their lives both
in their professional and their private
lives walk on eggshells I get people
messaging me going oh I really admire
your bravery I'm not what and they're
like yeah I couldn't say that I'm
terrified of my kid what my kids will
think and I'm thinking you're in your
50s in your 60s I mean let's be brutally
honest you don't know how much life
you've got left
and you're gonna walk around worried
about what your kids think
to me that's just really sad it's really
sad that people live like that it is it
is and you know what I I have like I
mean I have a very [__] up motivation
system personally but one of the most
inspiring and Powerful things that I
know and think about often is you say
you're in your 50s and 60s you know how
long you don't know how much longer
you've got left doesn't matter if you're
in your 20s you don't know you don't
know how much longer you've got left and
the reality is as well man is you know I
think people
I don't know if it was true for you but
for many people I think we we kind of
live through life waiting for something
to happen yeah for someone to come and
save us some yeah and the truth is no
one's coming no one's coming to save you
no one gives a [__] people are busy
living their own lives they're not
they're not sitting there judging you
and wondering what your opinion is about
this or that most of the time another
thing is you don't know when you're
gonna die but when you do
all that's going to happen is they're
going to put you in the ground to throw
some dirt on top and go and eat some
food yeah that's it that's it there's no
there's no big law okay look you you're
famous whatever there'll be lots of
people at the funeral but that's it
no nothing happens
and so
you might as well make the most of what
you've got
you might as well say what you think you
might as well be yourself
and you know when we you it's and people
will be watching this guy look at these
guys they've got a big YouTube channel
there so we started trigonometry for
precisely this reason we were not
prepared to
pretend to be people that we were not
yeah
and
also we started this with nothing yeah
and one of our best recent interviews
that we haven't released yet is with a
chap called Tim Urban and he was talking
about risk and he was talking about the
scale of risk so one being no risk 10
being
a high level of risk the highest level
of risks most people live their lives
between one and three but if you live
your life between four and seven that's
really the sweet spot right there that's
really where you you can actually
maximize risk and you can take risks and
and that's one of the reasons for me
were you know I was I was genuinely
proud of what you did with the Oxford
speech is because you went out there and
you took a risk
not a huge I'm going to put everything
don't worry darling everything is going
to go on the Grand National you know on
Punky horse I've got a feeling but it
was in that space and then when it went
big you deserved every single thing
you've got because you were willing to
stand up and say that thing that nobody
else had said
and that's why it went big and that's
why it worked and watching that made me
realize look when you comes to your own
comedy you need to go out and say the
thing you need to go out and say the
thing that you want to say and if people
get pissed off and people don't want to
work with you well them's a breaks well
and and for us we're in a fortunate
position now where reality is people can
dislike you or ban you from their Comedy
Club you're still going to find a way to
get your message out there to go and do
the comedy that you believe and if you
look at the comedy great
the people that you respect
that's what they all did absolutely and
if you think about the people that we
all respect the people who we look up to
who we idolize who we say you know
whoever it may be the writers the
thinkers The Poets the philosophers when
they were around they pissed a few
people off they won exactly Mr popular
right you know they these were people
who were controversial in their own
times yeah so if you want and if you
would aspire to be great then you have
to walk that walk and
it ain't easy and it's not gonna be
every day you wake up and it's going to
be plain sailing and it's going to be
relaxed since no it's going to be tough
and people are going to criticize you
and people aren't going to invite you to
things and people are going to
misrepresent you but that is the path
and you have to accept that and if you
don't want to accept that then you have
to accept living a life where you're
going to be inauthentic which to me is
the greatest punishment ever yeah
it's true
because you don't want to do that you
don't want to do that I mean we've both
lived a life where we didn't we weren't
everything that we could be
and as a result of that
it's I can't remember who said it's a
life of quiet despair in many ways
because you're not saying what you're
thinking or feeling well you're not
being true to yourself yeah right
um and that's the greatest luxury that
we now have is the ability to say what
we think and be ourselves I would say
afford state but
but yeah but that's what it is that's
what it is and you know what's really
lovely it's what I love so much
it's just being able to be ambitious
Without Shame
and not think that ambition is a bad
thing and it means you want to screw
people over and you know that you're
this help we've been spending time in
America haven't you yeah can't you and
it's Machiavellian it's none of these
things it's wonderful do you know what
man that is such a look you know how
much I love this country yeah but that
is such a thing that that thing always
used to bother me here I remember we uh
we went to see a comedy show
me you and someone else and we met a
fellow comedian outside who had just
opened for Ricky Gervais yeah
and I was like mate that's amazing
that's so great you've been slaving away
on the comedy circuit for 10 years now
you're opening one of the biggest acts
in the world anyone oh yeah I've been
really fortunate and I was like
the [__] are you talking about yeah but
everyone here sort of feel or most
people here sort of feel like they have
to pretend that their success is not
largely look like always plays a part
but largely down to their own hard graft
and this guy is a brilliant comic been
working away in relative obscurity in
terms of global comedy for years and
years and years and he's [__] earned
it yeah
and that that thing that they have in
the US where everyone you talk to in the
US is like look we might not get to work
together we might know this but I want
to see you win yeah and they mean it
yeah and I'm like that with people now
as well when people come in here
and they look at you like you're weird
they're like what yeah they look at you
like you're weird but they also love it
yeah they they like you know that
attitude of seeing other people win and
other people do well it's the best thing
and it's such a it's so good to be that
way for you yeah because you feel great
yeah
yeah of course of course the worst thing
I mean there's a saying in AA which is
people have heard it you know resentment
is drinking poison and hoping the other
person dies
do they say that when they fix your time
they do indeed they give you a little
bit of philosophy and then they get you
on your way but it's true man it's true
that way of thinking where you know you
don't deserve something if you get
something you don't deserve it and
you're worried about what other people
perceive about you but yeah if somebody
else gets something then you're
resentful living like that it's it's
just it's not good I don't have time for
it anymore man no and we are surrounded
the the beauty of of the work that we do
is we're surrounded by incredible people
yeah you know we've become very good
friends with Winston Marshall over the
you know the last couple years and he's
such a great guy and and so many others
so many other people that we terrible
tasting glasses but glasses yeah I'm
joking Winnie not what's wrong with his
glasses you know the the kind of it just
reminds me of my dad's in the 80s
I'm sorry I went
but um but no you're right you're right
just to be around people who are
ambitious and want to achieve things it
is such a tonic yeah uh and you know
something Eric Weinstein said when he
was in here made me think a lot which is
he talked about how you know I'd never
flown on a private plane until I got
canceled yeah
the truth of it is that
all of the energy all of the excitement
all of the really like stuff that makes
you feel alive is in our space now yeah
you know that yeah all the people that
we that we have on our show that we get
to hang out with that's where the
interesting conversations are happening
everything else is kind of stale I mean
if you look at the the party political
system for in in this country especially
we get someone on the right in here and
we ask them what they think of the
conservatives
we get someone on the Left End and we
ask them what they think about Labor no
one's excited about any of it no but
this space is exciting this space is
exciting this space is where things are
happening and this space is where
interesting fascinating conversations
are happening and
sometimes I have to stop and I have to
go appreciate what you have
because there are times you have this
amazing conversation
and then you go and chat to someone a
friend or whatever else and you just
relay what this person said and they're
like that's so interesting I've never
thought of the world like that who said
that to you how did they say that
but because it's our job
we get exposed to it all the time yeah
and it's it's it's an amazing thing to
be part of it is and we're we're going
to go back to the US indeed we are in a
month or so uh we've got some very big
plans we can't say yet other than we're
going back to Austin and uh La yeah and
maybe Vegas as well yeah for work yes
strictly speaking everything on black
like my dating history
uh uh so that would be really exciting
and we're working you know people can
already see that we are slowly starting
to expand the range of what we do here
so in addition to interviews you and I
put out uh pieces to camera uh regularly
we've got other creators who will be
coming through under our umbrella over
time and you know we are going from a
YouTube showing podcast to a media
organization a new Mini organization uh
and people are going to see some very
big uh changes here over the next six
months which is obviously very exciting
um and we'll talk more about that when
the time comes but we've got a brilliant
U.S trip coming up with some massive
guests and some some big appearances for
us as well so that should be fun it
should be really fun and what is also
important is that when people see the
change they realize as well that our
values will always remain the same we
will always be dedicated to having these
conversations the important ones I won't
sell to a billionaire in which case
Francis is going to change rapidly yeah
exactly mate head over straight over to
Italy and drown myself in carbs but the
values will always remain the same we
are always dedicated to having the
conversations with the most interesting
people about the topics that people are
scared to confront because it's only
when you talk about a topic honestly
all different facets of that topic can
you possibly hope to have an honest
conversation and that's why the
mainstream is dead and that's why no one
cares and that's why Louis Thoreau went
on at the uh I think the Edinburgh TV
festival and did an hour speech all
about this yeah
because the smart people know
they know they know what is happening
well Louis watches trigonometry so he
does indeed you know you know we look
alike you know he knows a sexy man when
he sees one but
and that's that's the exciting thing and
that's the exciting thing and whatever
happens and whatever we do we will
always retain those core values because
that's what makes the show great yeah do
you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash good
use our promo code which is also
triggered and get 50 off the initial
purchase sign up for their newsletter
access of easy which tells you
everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
it's been amazing to come to this point
it's been amazing to work with you it's
been amazing to work
and spend time and share and grow and
develop
and just see you develop and to see you
improve it's been a privilege it's been
a privilege because it's been a
privilege to me to see you get better
and it also makes me want to get better
and it makes me want to improve and
you're crushing it man I mean you're
doing lots of TV now we've got your
Clips coming out on the channel that are
doing really well you've done you've
been doing your comedy monologues which
uh are improving and growing over time
as well so uh you know I'm really
excited to see I've always said to you
and people won't know this but I've
always
I've always pushed you along sometimes
too much maybe or too forcefully at
least but I've always really believed in
you and the one thing I've always said
to you is
about your comedy but about life in
general is like you you've got the
handbrake on yeah and you've got to take
that handbrake off yeah you can't be
driving with the handbook and when you
really take that handbrake off with your
comedy
is going to be incredible yeah and it's
that realization of living in a state of
discomfort if you crave Comfort if you
crave security you are never going to
achieve well you're always overrated man
it's not it's overrated and it's not
real because even if you feel
comfortable you ain't safe
you may feel safe but you won't say no
and I think that's a great problem of
our age I think that's why people don't
achieve what they want I think it's why
they don't go after their dreams and I
think it's why ultimately they don't
live the life that they want you know
it's so interesting that this
conversation has been popping up quite a
lot in relation to depression because I
see a lot of people saying something
which I believe to be true which is the
way that we treat male and female
depression is the same even though
they're caused by very different things
and require very different solutions and
I think particularly for men the answer
to a lack of fulfillment a lack of
meaning and all the other things that
are likely to make a person depressed is
actually
stepping in to that risk and danger and
building something or doing something
that scares you but inspires you at the
same time and I've always since I was
quite young actually I've always people
won't believe this perhaps
um I did public speaking when I was at
school but then when I left school I you
know you know like you get those 18 year
old footballers they've come on the
pitch they've got no fear because they
don't have any concept of what's
Happening oh yeah they've got no idea
how high the steaks are no and then you
kind of get to to to your mid-20s and
suddenly you feel a little bit more
protective and whatever so by the time I
was in my mid-20s I was actually it's
probably fair to say that I was very
nervous about speaking in public I would
have been very nervous about being on
camera and I ran towards that and I
started I forced myself to do public
speaking I forced myself to train and
learn and whatever and I think for men
in particular this may be true of women
I don't know because I'm I'm not a woman
although I don't yeah yeah exactly
you
from I think for men
mental well-being comes first and
foremost from a feeling of
um
it's not power exactly but it's the
ability to make an impact and the
ability to take charge of your life that
really is what will offset any anxieties
or you know depressive Tendencies or
whatever you have because you are
inspired and you feel like you're
actually you've got some measure of
control level over life which isn't true
because you don't have full control of
your life but there are different
gradations of control and I think the
often the reason people feel lost is
that they they haven't really taken
charge
and you've been doing that in a really
impressive way and by the way you know
we I used to on Raw as I used to
jokingly fat shame you even lost tons of
weight you're pursuing your comedy in a
different way you're starting to write a
book now you've got a great book
proposal like you've really taken charge
of your life in the last few years and
it's really impressive to see men no
thank you very much and
what I want is for people to listen to
this and to watch this and realize that
I am special you ain't special none of
us are special the [__] is he talking
everyone can do this everyone can do
this all it requires is you make that
first step courage is a muscle the more
you work the muscle
the more courageous you will be and you
are never going to stop feeling fear
you're never going to stop feeling
scared you're never going to stop all of
those feelings you're just going to get
better at acknowledging them accepting
them working through them and then
moving forward that's all it is this
idea that you're going to get to a place
where you know you have somehow overcome
all of these emotions and fear that
ain't never gonna happen you're just
going to get better at dealing with it I
will say though I mean it you can get a
lot closer to like I for example what
the first time I did TV ever
I remember I remember pacing up and down
the hallway I was sweating buckets I was
nervous Etc yeah now I go on that very
same show and it's
and actually it freaks especially if I'm
doing like TV debates yeah when I did
the last time I was in Good Morning
Britain
it freaks the other guests out how calm
I am yeah and that's not because I'm
pretending to be anything I'm just like
I've been here I've done it I know what
it's like and so you will still feel
many of the same things but over time
you get comfortable in scary situations
absolutely and then you go to the next
level and you find okay this is good so
with my Oxford speech it was fascinating
because someone asked me were you like
nervous before you did it and when I was
driving over to Oxford to do it
I was completely calm yeah I knew I had
I knew exactly what I was going to say I
knew exactly how I was going to say it I
knew that it would look great on camera
and that it would do well really really
well
and afterwards when I'd done it I knew
that it would do really well it'd go
super viral it was a great speech
whatever
but the hour before hmm
I was re it's not even though I was
nervous it's just your body yeah
goes into that I'm about to be in front
of loads of people's stage in the new
context so the first time I did question
time which is the biggest show we have
in this country basically political
political show I remember being
completely calm and then I sat down and
the show started and I literally felt I
could not move my body except my head I
was that locked in I and I had to like I
had to really breathe yeah but then when
it got going I was fine the second time
completely calm the none of that so as
you have these experiences whatever it
is that you are nervous about or anxious
about or whatever
you learn over time and so you know
all the big shows that we get to do when
we go back on them we're going to feel
completely different yeah absolutely and
look if it goes I'll tell this story so
I presented a show on GB news which is
Headliners and they got me in and I was
very happy and they gave me the clicker
and I went to start and the clicker
froze and everything went wrong let's
take a look at those front pages The
Daily Mail are going with uh make coward
let me face us this is to do with nurse
letby who is
who is refusing to actually face
the the uh the the judge when she is
being sentenced
the times is now good is uh is going
with letby police fear that she attacked
30 more babies and I stumbled through it
and I didn't look very professional and
there was a few comments on Twitter and
people saying this and that and whatever
else and we modeled through
and that's it you wake up the next day
and everything's fine everything's fine
no one cares you move on with your life
and I think people need to realize as
well that the things that you think are
huge deals and in the moment they may be
and they may feel like it
and then everything just moves on you
know comedy is such a great training for
yeah for things going wrong in life in
that way because how many times have you
and I particularly when you're starting
out you go on stage you don't do very
well or you do really badly which can
happen occasionally but the thing is the
next day no one gives a [__] no one
remembers who you are no most of the
people in that audience God that guy
wasn't very good on whatever yeah
um but you feel so scary in the moment
oh it does it does it feels world is
ending it feels like you're being judged
and everything is falling apart in front
of your very eyes but it's just a moment
that's all it is that's all it is and
that's more than anything what for me
this journey has been part of it's just
just accepting the moment whatever the
moment is whether you're interviewing
Eric Weinstein I remember the first time
we interviewed Douglas Murray I I was
intimidated I was like oh this guy's so
intelligent he's so smart
but now I'm smarter than him so it's all
no but you just go look this is a guy
he's really smart he knows his stuff
let's have fun yeah and we do and I
think it shows in the interviews yeah
and you know also we've become better
interviewers one of the things people
don't realize is it's kind of hard in
our game in the New Media world where
you know you've spent months
chasing a guest yeah and then they come
on and they say something you don't
necessarily agree with initially when
you're starting out it can be tempting
to just let it go
whereas now I think we feel much more
confident about challenging people when
they say
things that don't make sense to us and
you and you've seen that in you know we
go into every interview with a ton of
good faith yeah
but
also if someone is saying something
that's not quite true we are going to
get to the bottom of it and you know for
all the concerns we had about how that
interview got spun and whatever into Sam
Harris last year is a good example and
when we go back to America we're gonna
we're gonna interview Sam again yeah and
I'm really looking forward to it so am I
and so you know that's the other thing
that's exciting is as we grow we have
the opportunity to get better yeah yeah
and that's that you know it's the
opportunity to get better it's the
opportunity to talk to people who are
the people that you really want to talk
to the people they've always dreamed of
talking to the people you've always
dreamed about having a conversation with
and just finding out who they are what
makes them work and what you can take
from them
you know and and it's the beautiful
thing about the American trips is that
it's all you know to sit opposite
someone like Bill but it's it's a thrill
it's a thrill to sit opposite Sam Harris
I listen to Sam's app every morning when
I meditate of course I do I meditate I'm
a [__] right but to talk to somebody
like that it's just it's a privilege
yeah it's a privilege and to go on Joe
Rogan and Bill Maher and all these other
incredible opportunities it's it's
Insanity I remember uh when I went to LA
I was just that La is such an
interesting place man it's deeply weird
and fascinating and fascinating but I
just remember standing there in the in
the streaming Sun yeah just thinking
what an amazing opportunity what an
amazing ride this has been yeah you know
and that you know we've we've been
talking about gratitude for a long time
here but it's so I I just think for us
it's really easy to be grateful yeah
because we started this and basically in
someone else's shed effectively as we
talked about and now you know we we
we're doing this incredible stuff how
could you not appreciate every moment
yeah you have to you have to take every
moment and appreciate it
and realizes well that the difficult
moments are going to teach you far more
than the good moments the good moments
are wonderful and you should Savor them
and you should you should treasure them
and you should put them away and lock
them away and just remember them as but
it's the moments when they're tough
that's the moment where you you are
forged as a human being and though in
the fires of when things were really
tough and you carried on pushing through
that's how you became the person that
you were because there's a lot of people
in that Journey who would have turned
around and given up
whatever the challenges are yeah and one
of the things I'm incredibly grateful
for is the you know amazing people who
watch and support the show yeah our
locals Community is grown a lot and it's
how we fund the show it's the biggest
single source of Revenue that we have so
when people sign up to locals and you
know some people give us 200 a month
some people give us seven dollars a
month wherever it is that is what allows
us to do what we do and to keep going so
you know every time we see we go in
there and we chat with people I just
feel so immensely grateful that we live
in a world now where people can find
each other they can find content that
they enjoy they can go you know what I
really believe in this and there have
been people at every step of the way uh
you know there's a guy called Tom who
who knew that we were struggling when we
were still in that shed quote unquote uh
and he really liked the show so he
bought us new cameras and microphones he
just bought them for us yeah and there
were other people who came along at
different points and uh gave us money or
the people who give us money regularly
that we've got Top Dog people who who
come and you know have lunch with us
every now and again and whatever and
without those people this will be
pointless we'd just be talking to
ourselves absolutely but
the reason the people helped is because
they could see us working and
metaphorically pushing that car up the
hill and if you do that and whatever and
whatever path or whatever industry you
work in there will always be people be
like I'll help
because people respect people who are
trying who are trying to achieve
something who are striving for something
because to me that's the human condition
when you stop striving for something
that's the moment when you you
effectively give up you'll no longer
achieving and I think a lot of the
reason why people get depressed or they
feel depression is because they're not
striving
they're going for something else they're
living in a state of fear they're
they're wanting comfort
but if you strive if you want to achieve
it's not going to be easy you may fail
things may go sidewards at some points
they're going to be part they're going
to be unforeseen difficulties
but it's the only way to live it is and
I'm just very grateful that we have that
opportunity so give us your money
absolutely I'm proud of everything that
we've achieved I'm excited oh mate the
next the rest of this year is going to
be absolutely dynamite and we've got I
mean the stuff we've got coming up yeah
it's exciting as hell
um in terms of what the media
organization that we're building is
going to look like we'll we'll be
talking more about that when the time is
right but also some of the stuff we're
going to get up to in America some of
the brilliant guests we've got lined up
here
um you know you you and I are going to
continue putting out comedic and
satirical stuff
um it's just there isn't like I said
there is no limit anymore there is no
limit to what we can achieve there is no
limit to what the organization can
achieve and also for the people at home
there's no limit to what you can achieve
what we want to do with this is fulfill
our dreams
but also as well we want to make an
impact so that people who watch our show
can think to themselves well I don't
want to create a YouTube channel but I
want to do X or Y or Z or whatever it
may be and that they can go ahead and do
that because it's by doing that that
actually you're empowering other people
which will then come back to you
well I agree and I think you know when
you talk about I'm not special you're
not special I know exactly what you mean
because
we were two circuit comedians who
neither of whom had had a massive
success you know
um we had nothing we had no money we had
no Studio had no producer we had no
cameras we had no microphones we had no
experience with any of that
um but we had an idea and we went for it
yeah that's really it and we worked
incredibly hard and we stuck together
through very difficult things and
um
and we I I feel like we're right at the
beginning of our journey this is for all
the enjoyment and the success that we've
had and how great we feel about where we
are this is just the beginning like I
said we've got an incredible team as
well of people that are working really
well together uh they're gonna drive
this whole thing forward for us and
allow us to just be the creative people
that we we started out being
um and that's you know there's so many
things and and look the the impact that
we want to make on the world is that we
live in these very
very superficial times
this culture of everything being
condensed into a tiny little tweet or
whatever that's not the way human
communication is supposed to be
and it's an it's almost a tragedy in the
sense that
Even in our own lives you and I
the conversations like this that you and
I have and the conversations we have on
our guests with our guests are probably
one of the few times in our lives in all
of our lives that we actually get to sit
down and connect with another human
being for an hour uninterrupted by
phones or whatever
and that is quite extraordinary that we
get to do that for a living and that we
get to share that with the world and
people can join in those conversations
and see people who are actually
communicating in a way that human beings
are supposed to communicate you know in
a world that really really very rarely
has the opportunity for people to do
that yeah and that's why it's so
important that we do what we do because
we live in this world we know it's been
said many times but it's true and it
makes people miserable because you don't
sort anything out you don't discover
anything you don't play
on social media or doing these little
sound bites or watching TV which is why
no one watches it anymore because it's
inherently fake every single thing about
it
so
as we move forward
we're going to be doing more interviews
more conversation
and talking to people who
are going to be
even more exciting
can't wait so follow us on social media
head on over to locals And subscribe
there and we'll see you very soon with
more amazing content take care
[Music]